so when filmmakers sit down to negotiate
a distribution deal for their movie what
happens who initiates it who speaks
first what points are typically brought
up um it happens in a lot of different
ways you know let's take a typical
example we just got back from Sundance
so we'll take a Sundance film that is
lucky enough to get distribution while
they're there there's interest from
buyers typically what happens is there's
a sales agent involved and that sales
agent will take the lead on the
negotiations and when we get involved is
serve at that same time but in a little
bit of a different role so simply put
the sales agent will negotiate the
material deal points what rights am I
getting how much money are they going to
pay me how long is the term going to be
and we will come in and make sure that
especially we've been on since the
beginning and we really understand the
project just to make sure that there's
no rights that are being granted that
conflict with something that the
filmmaker has expressed to us before you
sons were working a music doc and they
want to retain the soundtrack rights but
the sales agent doesn't know that and
the sales agent gives away the
soundtrack rights and then it becomes a
big issue later on so it's good for us
to be involved at that early stage so
that we can make sure that the deal is
appropriate for the client and makes
sense and then we also come in again
when there's a longer form agreement to
negotiate we really start delving into
the into issues like delivery what do
they need to deliver you know deliver
the a delivery list that's attached to a
distribution agreement can be quite
onerous and quite expensive and if the
filmmaker isn't careful to go through
that and understand exactly what they
need to deliver could cost them tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
dollars to deliver a film and maybe
they're only getting in advance of
$50,000 it doesn't really make a lot of
sense so that's an important thing that
we make sure the filmmaker understands
everything that to deliver and going
through that with them and then again
all of the terms in the contract
well would some of those items be that
they would need to deliver on well most
of them which are above my head but
technical items that they have to
deliver do they need to deliver a
35-millimeter print do they have to what
kind of digital format do they need how
much how many publicity stills do they
need to deliver do they need to deliver
artwork do they need to make their own
trailer you know there's all of those
issues that sometimes the producer just
assumes the studio is gonna do that and
sometimes they're not going to so it
really depends in other circumstances
they may want it the students say we're
doing this trailer we're not trusting
you to do the trailer we're the
marketing experts but other times they
want that stuff to be delivered what are
some of the typical terms in a
distribution agreement whether it's
theatrical or VOD so what that depends
you know I guess more like it is it
doesn't we've had it all distribution
agreements you're gonna have the term so
how long are you giving them the rights
for and really we look at that it's very
dependent on money you know if you're
paying a lot of money for this
acquisition if you're paying seven
million dollars for a film the acquirer
is going to get probably all the rights
and they're probably gonna get it in
perpetuity if someone isn't giving no
advance we might say okay we'll give you
broadcast rights let's say you're CNN
and you're giving a $50,000 advance and
this is totally just an example not true
we're gonna say obviously and you can
have the broadcast rights but I'm
retaining everything else I want the
rights to go someplace else to
distribute this digitally I want the
ability to monetize this elsewhere
because you're not giving me enough
money to recoup my expenses pay back my
investors etc
you